it wasn't real
[Music]
they were just messing with my head hey
youtubers is Charlie in agents that
she'll finally showed us what a magical
place Tahiti was that's right we found
out how agent coulson survived up to the
Avengers and we find out what happened
to Mike Peterson after the last episode
turns out the comic book rule holds true
you never die completely or maybe it's
that no one can't be brought back from
the dead at least if you're a super
soldier or Nick Fury's BFF so lots to
talk about this time we even got some
clues as to the identity of the
clairvoyant so I'm gonna do my top 5
moments then I'll do my review and then
I'll talk about who I think the
clairvoyant is number 5 Skye does her
best Melinda may impression in my head
all I could hear was her bowing between
takes on set and saying this one is for
the Oscar and even though the whole
thing was a little bit on the nose I did
laughs the minute the camera just
started panning slowly up and she said
her name was bull into May and yet the
sunglasses shot number 4 all Rochambeau
you for it the other option would have
been rock paper scissors so I wonder if
they just said Rochambeau because
they're British the last time I heard a
character used that phrase on TV it was
Eric Cartman in a really old episode of
South Park considering the award was in
super hardcore interrogation mode
whenever they cut back to Fitz for that
line it was pretty funny I did laugh
pretty hard number 3 Coulson can't stop
saying it's a magical place the most
interesting part of this is that clearly
there's some mental trigger in his head
for saying that whenever he says the
word Tahiti we don't necessarily need to
know why he can't stop saying that
phrase it's just meant to be an
indicator that whatever's inside his
head is just too dangerous for even him
to know so there's a big mental block
stopping him from knowing number 2 Mike
Peterson is co-opted by the clairvoyant
so Mike is none the worse for wear you
know minus a leg in a holding cell but
now he's got this same control tech that
Coulson's old field agent had so he's
basically gonna be forced to work for
the villains now I can't wait to see the
showdown between him and Melinda may
it'll be the super soldier versus the
cavalry I feel like you could sell
ringside seats to that the MMA fight of
the decade and my number one moment the
magical place if you didn't feel like
they explained it well enough here's
what happened to Coulson he was dead for
a few days after the events of the
Avengers but because you can keep the
brain alive by stimulating it
electrically and maintaining blood flow
Nick Fury basically did a bunch of crazy
surgeries to repair the rest of his body
the robot was there to keep his brain
alive while they were performing all
those surgeries
the reason they implanted the tahiti
memory
because all of those surgeries were so
awful that's why Coulson was screaming
at them to let him die
so let me know what your favorite moment
was and let me know if you were
satisfied with the explanation of how
Coulson survived overall I felt the
episode was a strong comeback for the
second half of the season obviously they
kind of teed up basically the storyline
the second half of the season is gonna
be hunting down the clairvoyant now that
it's on shields [ __ ] list they kept
talking about the fridge so obviously
it's some sort of big prison but I'm
kind of wondering now if there's a deep
freeze - I also kind of thought that
Coulson was going to give Skye the info
on her parents whenever he went to take
her bracelet off I think that will come
back in the next episode did anyone else
think of sharknado whenever they started
talking about super storms with that CG
hurricane in the background Marvel
sharknado that sounds like it belongs in
a Deadpool show Deadpool versus a
sharknado but let's talk about the
clairvoyant now so based on a lot of the
things that the characters said about it
and the way they described it it sounds
a lot like it's an AI think about it
this way Marvel does a really good job
of teeing up ideas you know years in
advance four things are gonna happen in
the movies so the next big villain in
Avengers 2 is going to be Ultron you
know an evil AI so why wouldn't they T
it up in a TV show two years in advance
and think about it
Raina was talking about how the
clairvoyant was giving them formulas
Coulson said that it knew lots of
personal information but an AI could
totally grab that from your cell phone
from your home harddrive from the things
that you said in your security cameras
and what about my Petersen whatever the
instructions started reading across his
eyeballs I got this really strong AI
vibe and think about Skye - obviously
what's her role on the team she's like
the hacker what would be a better
showdown in the finale than watching her
go up against an evil AI I'm just saying
it Ultron's coming in a couple years so
they're obviously gonna have to tee up
the idea somehow and why wouldn't they
do that in the big TV show let me know
what you think though is the clairvoyant
in AI or is it a real person in other
news I'm working on a predictions video
for the second half of arrow season 2 be
sure to subscribe to get it I'll add an
annotation right here whenever I post
that video and you can click here to get
my predictions for The Walking Dead this
season thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives
you